good morning John I'm sleepy and there's
a lot going on and I'm making this video
substantially ahead of time because pod
count is happening this weekend and I
will admit that to a certain extent not
my personal life but with the world at
large of kind of sort a little bit had a
I am feeling grumpy and I like to put
positive energy out in the world but
also I like to be myself and I like to
experience the emotions that I'm
experiencing and I found in my pocket of
this jean jacket questions from when we
did live to your Hank and John's while
on tour we're gonna do a live dear Hank
and John at pod con so that's gonna be
great what's this this is just a coaster
from my hotel so I wanted to answer some
of these questions I don't know if we
answered them on tour I don't know why
they're in my pocket but I will say that
these are not necessarily answers that I
would get if I were in a good mood I'm
very excited from Potkin very excited to
do all the stuff I'm doing in my life my
actual life project for awesome is
coming my baby is very cute everything
is good in my personal and professional
life but I don't know if you've heard
about the rest of the world all right
let's do the questions how can you be
supportive when a friend of yours gets a
haircut you find really weird all
haircuts are weird what other organism
is like I was not my hair let grow
forever it's gonna get it's like imagine
a zebra out it's like galloping along
tripping over its fur people are so
weird our hair grows forever and the
only other organisms that do this are
freaking domesticated dogs that we bred
to have dumb hair all haircuts are weird
what if like Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz
I want to believe that there's no place
like home but also I don't know exactly
where home is
Rachael welcome to adulthood this is
from Lindsey who asked what should be
the signature dish that I baked to
impress new friends your signature dish
I mean nachos go in the oven right what
else do you bake bake bake potatoes
baked potatoes this gets in gravy hot
corn dog do you bake corn dogs you baked
no you don't you fry this is from
Anthony my brother spends a lot of time
at home alone I came home to him playing
guitar and singing I didn't know he did
either of those things I spoiled his
secret talent how do I tell him don't
tell him this is his secret he wants to
be CP he wants to let you guys know in
his own time it's gonna be really a lot
of pressure at that stage between when
you like don't know anything and then
you start to get kinda good at stuff if
there's this huge gap
between okay and good and you don't know
about that gap in the beginning there's
like anybody who could do anything with
the guitars magic and if you don't know
what's going on I would let him practice
in peace and he says you're doing very
great sweetie thank you that that help
this world is a tendency not to be as
awesome as it should be brothers would
you be willing to support me in becoming
the world's dictator below that it says
your loyalty will be rewarded
I mean Dakota you had me until the end
there as a turtle biologist I must ask
what is your favorite kind of turtle I
know I just realized I'm a turtle face
what I read that I like sea turtles a
lot they're really good especially baby
ones oh boy Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
I like turtle men like doctor ones
turtle man our popular thing I've done
on vlogbrothers that maybe ever and I
write sometimes it feels really stupid
and bad writing when I read it back it's
way better than I thought but this makes
me question my writing does this happen
to you yes it totally does the thing to
like give credence to it's not like in
the moment you're thinking about it and
you fixing and breaking and reforming
it's after you have done that reading it
and how do you feel about that final
product not the terrible mess in between
how will I ever know if I've actually
succeeded mica let me tell you friend
that doesn't happen you will never know
you will succeed in individual events
but failure will always be just around
the corner so find things that sustain
you that our aren't imaginary like
friends John I'll see you on Thursday
also hey John free domestic shipping at
dftba.com for the next three days if you
order $80 or more yeah